[Music]
several states including new york
california and texas
say they will not follow controversial
new guidance
on coronavirus testing the cdc had
recommended tests for anyone who came in
close contact
with an infected person this week though
the agency revised that saying people
exposed to the virus
who don't show symptoms may not need to
be tested
the exposure issue is getting new
attention after the huge
annual motorcycle rally in sturgis south
dakota this month that's been linked
to dozens of new cases chief medical
correspondent dr john lapook shows us
why the cdc's change is alarming many
in the medical community if you've had a
high risk exposure you should be tested
dr tom inglesby is an internationally
recognized authority on infectious
diseases
and the director of the johns hopkins
center for health security
he says he does not agree with the
centers for disease control's new
guidance on testing
we've been told that contact tracing is
the meat and potatoes
of trying to stop an epidemic or a
pandemic how does this interfere with
that
if we stop testing contacts we lose
information about what's going on in our
own community
we know that something on the order of
40 to 50 percent of people with this
disease in the united states
don't have symptoms there are a lot of
people who are asymptomatic who
are at risk of spreading this disease
let's say on day one
person a is in close contact with person
b and nine days later finds out person b
has just been diagnosed with covid19
as early as day three person a could
have started
asymptomatically infecting others if
person a goes into self-quarantine
without being tested
those contacts may not be notified of
their exposure to coronavirus
and may go on to infect others i got an
example of
someone i know whose uh
child was just exposed to a coveted case
that child is going to stay home for two
weeks no matter what
but if that child also tests positive
then family members
have clear risk and
others in her life might have clear risk
a federal health official tells cbs news
the push for the change in guidance came
from the department of health and human
services
and the white house coronavirus task
force when you do
testing to that extent you're gonna find
more people you're gonna find more cases
throughout the summer president trump
repeatedly blamed widespread testing for
generating alarming case numbers
and headlines on thursday the vice
president's chief of staff
mark short said one reason for the
change to the cdc's guidance
was the long wait for test results the
guidance that was updated
is because there continue to be backlogs
in the system with the testing
particularly for people getting tests or
asymptomatic
but dr inglesby says the change does not
solve that problem
the solution to that is to fix the
turnaround time the solution
is not just to slow down testing or to
start eliminating groups of people who
need to be tested
a few days after the guidance change the
department of health and human services
said in a statement
the guidelines received appropriate
attention consultation and input
from fellow task force experts including
cdc director redfield
who advised coronavirus-related matters
among departments and agencies
and cdc director dr robert redfield
released a nearly identical statement
but included a recommendation that
people who have been exposed
talk to their health care provider or to
a public health official
about whether or not to get tested john
what are other experts in the medical
community saying about these changes
anthony they're confused and they're
upset and
my sources tell me that inside the cdc
there was disagreement
about that policy change which is why
you saw dr redfield come out a few days
ago
and try to clarify things by saying look
if you've been exposed to somebody
you're asymptomatic you're exposed to
somebody who's infected with covid
you can consider getting tested but the
infectious diseases expert i spoke to
most of them all of them actually
uniformly said they don't want to just
consider being tested they want the
person to be tested because we've
learned
that asymptomatic spread of coronavirus
is extremely
important in this pandemic yeah and as
you point out making these changes does
not solve the problem in delayed testing
results
john thank you very much